trailer Matt wall show another major
dictionary tries to meet the what is a
woman challenge by redefining the word
it's an orwellian move and even worse
the redefinition makes no sense at all
of course also a trans-identified male
physically assaults two girls in the
girl's bathroom something we continually
are told never happens a member of a
Human Rights Commission resigns after
going on an absolutely unhinged rant
against Christmas trees and four nurses
are fired for airing their complaints
against their patients in a tick tock
video all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
foreign
coffee company is helping you knock out
your holiday shopping with a ton of
awesome new products this year shop the
best Brewing gear thermoses mugs and
apparel designed for folks who love
country and coffee Black Rifle coffee
sources the most exotic roast from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the US by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts you can stuff your
Christmas stockings with the latest Rose
from America's coffee for 10 off with my
code Walsh better yet sign your Secret
Santa up for a coffee Club subscription
imagine the joy of a pre-scheduled
coffee delivery your favorite roast when
you need the most it's the gift that
keeps on giving Black Rifle coffee is
veteran founded and operated they take
pride in serving coffee and culture to
people who love America every purchase
you make with Black Rifle coffee helps
support veteran and first responder
causes so go to Black riflecoffee.com
use promo code walls for 10 off coffee
Coffee Gear apparel or when you sign up
for a new coffee Club subscription
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code Walsh for 10 off Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
definitions are important if I were to
summarize my work over the last couple
of years in one sentence that would
perhaps be the best summary words must
have definitions and we must know what
those definitions are we cannot
communicate we cannot express ourselves
meaningfully we cannot convey any ideas
or get across any message about anything
if words don't have meaning and if we
don't all know and recognize the meaning
words cannot be subjectively defined it
cannot be left up to each individual on
their own to decide what any given word
means because the essence of language is
that it is shared it is a way for people
to convey meaning to each other but
that's not possible if words and their
definitions are not communally
understood
this of course has been the Crux of the
what is a woman argument the word woman
must mean something or else it means
nothing and if it means nothing then it
cannot be meaningfully used in
communication between people a man
cannot coherently say I identify as a
woman if the word woman doesn't mean
anything because then he is identifying
as nothing yet the only definition of
the word that anyone has ever been able
to offer is one that would exclude the
man claiming the title for himself so
the man is in a bind either the word
woman means something in which case he
cannot be a woman or it means nothing in
which case
he still cannot be a woman this is the
position that the left finds itself in
when you ask what is a woman and it's
why the question what is a woman has
proven to be if I may say so one of the
most effective counter arguments against
the left ever period
in fact it's been so effective and
devastating that they are now literally
rewriting the dictionary in response to
it as a National Review reports today
the Cambridge Dictionary has added a new
quote trans-inclusive definition of the
word woman this is apparently done
sometime last week the Cambridge
Dictionary supplemented its original
definition of woman which is still adult
female human being that's definition one
and now they've added in the last few
days this secondary definition which is
this
an adult who lives and identifies as
female though they may have been said to
have a different sex at Birth
now this is very similar to the move
pulled by Merriam-Webster's Dictionary a
few months ago which left the word woman
untouched didn't didn't change that
definition so the definition for a woman
in Merriam-Webster is still adult human
female
but then you ask what's a female and
well they added a new definition of
female which now reads having a gender
identity that is the opposite of male
and obviously in both cases uh you know
Miriam Webster they also change the
definition of mail uh and then uh the
Cambridge dictionaries also changed the
definition of man
of course the problem with this
attempted Rebrand is that it's totally
nonsensical in both cases with Cambridge
as well as Webster the new definitions
contradict Common Sense science and even
the left's own narrative
and it accomplishes the latter feat by
conflating sex and gender two categories
that the left still pretends to insist
are distinct so to hear them tell it
according to them a woman is a gender
while female is a sex now they've never
been clear about what this distinction
is actually supposed to mean because it
doesn't really mean anything
but whatever the distinction is meant to
be both dictionaries have erased it by
treating Woman as a sex and female as a
gender identity
but obviously it's going to contradict
the orthodoxies of gender ideology you
cannot make any statement about sex or
gender that doesn't contradict some
aspect of gender ideology as the entire
thing is a confused pretzel of competing
mutually exclusive claims and internal
inconsistencies
the greater problem
is that these definitions fly in the
face of basic logic not to mention human
biology
so they say a woman is an adult who
lives and identifies as female though
they may have been said to have been a
different sex at Birth
according to the Cambridge Dictionary
but
how can someone
live as a female if they are not female
I mean to live as something is to be
that thing you cannot be something and
yet not live as it just as you cannot
live as something if you are not that
thing
unless unless by live as we really mean
living in the manner of or living as an
imitation of
and if that's what's meant here and it
is what's meant because that's all it
that could possibly be meant by it then
the Cambridge Dictionary is actually
telling us that a woman is either an
adult human female or not an adult human
female
it is claiming that a person who
imitates something is definitionally
identical to a person who is that thing
but if that's true I mean if to imitate
it is to be it then there's no need to
add this second definition in the first
place if trans women are simply women
then they're already included under the
original definition and there's no need
to expand it but if a new definition
needs to be added in order to include
so-called trans women that proves in and
of itself that so-called trans women are
in a different definitional category
so think of it this way a woman
by her nature
has a uterus
um this is this is part of what is meant
when we talk about you know an adult
human female
a man who identifies as a woman
is attempting to live as someone who has
a uterus a female even though he doesn't
have one so Cambridge Dictionary is now
telling us therefore that there is no
difference between having a uterus and
not having one
there is no difference between a thing
and the negation of that thing
there is no difference between one and
zero there is no difference between
something and its opposite
they're not just erasing women they're
they are erasing the concept of
differences
even things that are different are still
somehow not different
we have descended into pure nonsense we
literally cannot make sense of this
because there is no sense to make
but we can arrive at one conclusion
which is that
we are winning the argument
dictionaries frantically changing their
definitions that is in admission that
definitions matter
and that they must be objective and
shared
and the fact that the new definitions
are totally incoherent and ridiculous
and cannot be understood even on their
own terms
is an inadvertent admission that
everything we've said about gender
ideology is correct
the left cannot ignore the what is a
woman question they know that they want
to but they know they can't
and and yet they cannot meet the
challenge it poses to them without
wildly contradicting not only biology
and logic but even themselves in the
process
we win
the game is over
the dictionaries can say whatever they
want
they cannot rescue the left here though
after all dictionary definitions are
descriptive they're not proscriptive
Cambridge Dictionary doesn't decide what
a word means okay it's not up to them to
decide
it if it's if the dictionary is
functioning properly it merely records
what the word means
so they could rewrite the definition of
elephant to say an elephant is a small
round fruit that grows on a tree
but this editorial decision would not
actually cause elephants to suddenly
start growing on trees elephants would
still exist just as they did before
they are things that occur in nature
they are a physical reality they have
certain objective properties whether we
choose to recognize that or not
likewise women exist in nature as a
distinct biological category with
certain natural abilities and functions
and possessing certain common traits
the category exists so we could abolish
every word that describes the category
or we could simply refuse to use the
words that describe the category and yet
the category itself would remain
the truth remains
because the truth does not require our
permission or our acknowledgment
you can you can close your eyes you know
it's like little kids uh they close
their eyes or they cover their eyes and
they think that they think that
everything around them is disappeared
they think that they've disappeared
because they because they're refusing to
look
well no you can close your eyes but the
thing is still there
it just is and that's it
only one side of the gender ideology
debate is interested in recognizing this
truth
only one side can speak coherently and
intelligibly about that truth
and so we win the argument
now the other side will continue arguing
no doubt they'll continue saying things
but it's all Sound and Fury signifying
nothing
we've already won
now let's get to our five headlines
inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and
the team at front page magazine has been
unmasking these totalitarians since the
earliest days of the internet founded by
David Horowitz a former red diaper baby
and new leftist who ultimately became an
enemy of the left and a best-selling
author front page magazine has spent
over two decades combating the radical
left's efforts to destroy America there
are two new podcasts the right tank with
Mark tapson and the Jason Hill show
offer riveting interviews and insightful
coverage of politics culture and current
events the right take with Mark Thompson
offers a fascinating in-depth cultural
commentary as well as interviews with
well-known conservative thinkers like
Heather McDonald Michael Walsh and many
others the Jason Hill show offers
thoughtful deep Dives about the
ideologies of the radical left and
interviews with renowned public
intellect intellectuals like Peter wood
and Bruce Gilley it takes a village to
combat the radical left efforts to
destroy America that's why he's a fan of
my show you should also check out these
guys over front page magazine by
visiting
frontpagemag.com while you're there
support their cause by making a tax
deductible donation inside every
Progressive is a totalitarian screaming
to get out and no one understands that
better than the team at front page
magazine check out frontpagemag.com
today
We Begin here with uh the website Redux
which does a lot of actually important
journalism and here's another example of
that it says two female students have
been left with injuries after reportedly
being reportedly being assaulted by a
trans-identified male student in the
women's restroom at a high school in
Edmond Oklahoma Redux has obtained a
police report related to a violent
assault that took place in a women's
washroom at Edmond Memorial High School
the report dated October 26th reveals
that a trans-identified male student was
handed a juvenile summons after two
female students were left with injuries
following a fight he had reportedly
initiated with them in the women's
washroom on October 26th at
approximately 8 A.M police responded to
reports of a fight that had broken out
at Memorial High School in the small
community of Edmond Oklahoma upon
arriving the officer found a female
student with injuries to her face and
head at the nurse's station the
attending officer noted the female
victim had several red areas on her face
and that both of her eyes were beginning
to swell the officer conducted an
interview with the victim whose full
name was redacted due to age the female
student advised the officer that a
trans-identified student indicated by
the letter A had approached her in the
women's bathroom while she was speaking
to her friends she explained that a had
tried to talk to her and she'd ignored
him at which point a began to get angry
and asked if she wanted to fight while
approaching her with bald Fists
the victim said the trans identified
student then hit her in the face and she
indicated her statement that she uh was
not strong enough to fight back due to
the force of the blow the transgender
student pulled the girl's hair and
forced her to the ground at which point
he began to kick her in the face and
punch her repeatedly
the victim's friends who had been in the
washroom at the time witnessed the
incident and were pleading with a to
stop his assault one of the other female
students attempted to intervene and was
punched twice on the left side of her
face by the assailant
one witness indicated that the girl had
tried to step in because a is a man
quote unquote and she felt her student
her friend's life was at was at risk the
female student who interviewed
intervened as listed as having injuries
to her eye face and head with a possible
concussion
uh now a statement from the transgender
student indicates that he had initiated
conversation with the victim because he
was trying to pay her back for clothes
he had stolen from her
the student also contradicts the victim
and witness statements and provides
details that are inconsistent with the
girls injuries as recorded by police
so this happened back in October first
time we're hearing about it
because of course the media has
absolutely no interest
in in these kinds of uh stories and and
there's there's almost no interest or
motivation
certainly don't interest the motivation
in the corporate media to report on them
uh oftentimes there's very little
interest on the part of the school to uh
to report these crimes in this case the
school did did the right thing
but as we saw in Loudoun County
oftentimes that's not the case
there's much more of an interest in
covering it up so the point is we don't
actually know we hear about these cases
now we hear from the left
that this that this never happens okay
it's just it's a it's a fantasy you're
not going to have
trans identified males who are going
into women's locker rooms and bathrooms
and assault physically assaulting
sexually assaulting whatever it is
um uh women they say it doesn't have
well we know it does happen because we
hear about the cases
but the cases that we hear about are
it's it's in spite of the best efforts
to prevent us from hearing about it so
we don't even know how common this
actually is
and it's obviously no surprise
um well it's no surprised to hear about
the fact that he's still closed and even
he even he admits to that so this this
appears to be a little bit of a trend
you know think about the Sam Britain
case but it's also no surprise
when we hear about incidents like this
and we see acts of violence against
women carried out by quote unquote trans
people in bathrooms and locker rooms and
so on because how could it be a surprise
their very presence in that space
is an act of violence in and of itself
Okay so
uh for a man to enter into a private
female space
where females are vulnerable and exposed
that is an act of sexual harassment in
and of itself for a man to knowingly
walk into a women's bathroom that's
sexual harassment just to be there in
the first place
um you are an abuser simply by walking
into the room
so we make a mistake uh and
conservatives made a mistake for a while
when we have the bathroom debate and we
we Center it around you know
hypotheticals about what about men who
might pretend quote unquote to be trans
just so that for nefarious purposes they
can gain access to the bathroom or the
locker room and yeah that is a concern I
mean we we know for sure that that
happens
and I think that's probably even more
common uh in in prisons where you have
male prisoners who just out of whole
cloth invent their quote trans identity
as a way to access the women's PR
women's prison
so we know that that sort of thing
happens
but
when we sent our argument around that it
makes it sound like well we're not
concerned about the sincere trans people
you know if there's some way to
determine the insincere trans men from
the sincere ones then it would be no
issue at all
I don't care if they're sincere or not
it's like either it's a man pretending
to be confused about his gender or he's
sincerely confused either way doesn't
make a difference
it's not suddenly better if the if the
man is actually confused and he's going
into the women's restroom because that's
what we mean when we say sincerely or
really trans trans as a as a as a
category is imaginary it's a human
invention
so there's no way to be really trans but
you can be really confused about your
identity that does exist
but either way
no matter what your intentions are or
your motivations
being there in the first place
is a problem it's an act of violence
your presence is an intrusion it is
abusive
so there is no question about whether
men in the women's room are a threat
are they a threat yes how do I know
because they're in the room because
they're there
just like if somebody walks into your
house in the middle of the night
you know you don't need to wonder if
they're a threat they're in your house
it doesn't matter what they do once
they're inside I mean it it matters they
could make the situation even worse
depending on how they behave once they
get there but my point is that by
walking in the door they are already
perpetrating a violent and intrusive Act
same for men who walk into the women's
room of the locker room just by walking
in that door that is an act of violence
against the women that are in there
there's a threat is intimidation this is
all based around intimidation
none of these women actually want the
men in there none of them do
why would they
because there is there is there even one
actual Woman in real life who actively
wants males to come into the locker room
with them
no but there are plenty of women who
won't speak out because they're they've
been intimidated into silence
and there are others who pretend that
they want that
these are minority
but of course you wouldn't want that
so it is an act of violence just being
in the room and that's you know and
that's uh of course you you say that and
the left will will uh
scoff at it
um to say the least
but these are the same people that find
acts of violence everywhere you know
they think that a tweet can be violent
they think an opinion can be violent
they think a joke could be an act of
violence
and of course in all those cases that's
absurd
but walking into the locker room or the
bathroom that is an actual physical act
that you are it's not just an opinion
you are physically doing something
all right here's some good news
accountability for a change
um actually two examples of
accountability quick uh quick update
first on a story from yesterday it says
an Upper Moreland School Board member
said she would uh not vote for the only
white CIS man quote unquote on the board
for the role of President because it
sends the wrong message to community we
played that clip for yesterday a
Pennsylvania School Board member who
refused to vote for the only CIS white
male on the board to serve as president
has decided to resign from a position at
the start of 2023.
um Upper Moreland School District Board
member Jennifer solut made the comments
during an open school board meeting on
December 6th just before a vote was held
to appoint a new board president
and uh
now she's actually going to resign
because there was enough of a backlash
against this that
now she should be fired rather than
being given the opportunity to resign
but I'll take that it's the best we
could do
and it's a it's a it's a
good sign at least that there's some
accountability here
there's a reason why she felt
perfectly free to say this she didn't
think there'd be a problem
because she lives in an environment
where well of course I can I can uh
express my bigoted views against uh
heterosexual white men because this is
what you know it's like this is the
environment she lives in she never
thought this is the atmosphere
so she thought she'd be perfectly I'm
sure this is not the first time that
she's expressed such views publicly
I would assume
she thought she'd get away with it here
but um but she couldn't
is that a sign that things are finally
changing
um that people are finally willing to
speak up and say you know what no
actually it's not okay it's not you know
it's not suddenly okay
to be bigoted against a group of people
based on their gender or their race as
long as it's white males
um also there's this a member of a
Boston suburbs Human Rights Commission
resigned after posting in a
profanity-laden post to Facebook last
week that mocked God and cursed her
fellow citizens amid controversy
regarding a local library's Christmas
trees
so the town of Dedham Massachusetts
about 30 miles Southwest of Boston to
national attention after Lisa Desmond
the manager of the local uh Endicott
Branch Library wrote on Facebook earlier
this month that its annual Christmas
tree display had apparently been
canceled to prevent offending people
Desmond wrote I've never posted a
negative post on Facebook that is until
now I found out today that my beautiful
Library will not have its Christmas tree
this year when I asked I was told that
people were made uncomfortable last year
looking at it sorry what in my 28 years
of uh at the library I have never heard
a negative comment
uh yeah because it was probably just one
person I mean how can you I I don't care
what your religion is if you don't have
a religion
it doesn't even seem physically possible
to uh
conjure feelings of anger or revulsion
when you're looking at a Christmas tree
it's just a it's a naturally joyous it's
like doesn't it make anyone smile to see
a Christmas tree could even make me
smile so how could you manage to
actually be upset
doing an anger looking at a Christmas
tree
of all things
well most people campus probably one
person so for 28 years they had a
Christmas tree no problems no one ever
expressed one single
ounce of of anger about it
one person comes along after almost
three decades and says you know I really
don't like that okay well yes sir we'll
take it right down
Desmond noted that the town historically
has celebrated and included everyone in
our community and she happily
participated in a recent Juneteenth
celebration at the library last summer
uh Diane loud Who was appointed to the
Human Rights Commission in Massachusetts
by the town's Commission on disability
reportedly called Desmond a selfish
effing bee and a subsequent Facebook
post that accused her of endangering
lives by raising the issue
she wrote for a tree for a mother effing
tree you've put people's lives in a lot
of danger a lot of danger
so a Christmas tree puts people's lives
in danger
I'm not exactly sure maybe if the tree
falls over on you or if it
if it's a real tree and you're not
watering it enough and it could become a
fire hazard I mean that's real so is
that what you means I don't think so
addressing others she speculated might
also have been responsible for bringing
the controversy to wider attention loud
continued in part
I hope you know the fact that you who
claim to Believe In Christ and Christmas
or whatever happy horse s you're trying
to hide behind are the least gracious
most hateful most disgusting trash in
the world
is this what you think your magic Sky
daddy wants where in the Bible was this
again
in closing I would like to add an Fu you
pieces of trash
I hate each and every one of you and I
do wish great suffering on you you're
terrible terrible people you did it all
because you didn't get your way you're
despicable
this is about a Christmas tree
I always thought that the story of like
the Grinch who stole Christmas was it
was you know it's a little hard to get
invested in because it's just not very
realistic like how could anyone hate
Christmas that much but here here we go
this is the person that the story was
based on I guess
um
and uh it says loud participated earlier
this year in an LGBT Pride event hosted
by the town of Dedham and it's HRC Human
Rights Commission where she was joined
by her by her grown child Max who
discovered his transgender identity at
the age of 13. all right big surprise
there so
so Diane loud with with a very
appropriate last name I must say sounds
like a just a deeply miserable person a
horrendously unpleasant human being all
around no wonder she has a trans kid
she's exactly the kind of adult
exactly the kind of especially over
domineering uh left-wing mentally
unstable mother
who ends up having a trans child just by
coincidence no it's not a coincidence
because she imposes that identity on her
child
um no surprise there
but I really want to focus on the fact
that
she's an anti-christian atheist
with the Human Rights Commission or she
was with the Human Rights Commission
and this is this is a problem that goes
far beyond just this one individual so
it's a bigger issue
um and I'm sure this never occurred to
her because she doesn't seem like the
sort of person who makes a habit of you
know thinking much less thinking
self-critically
but
you cannot be involved in protecting or
preserving human rights
as an anti-christian atheist
it doesn't really make any sense
it doesn't and as I said this is a
problem that goes far beyond Mrs loud
I'm going to say Miss loud because I'm
assuming she's not married
um
it goes far beyond that
it's like if you're if you're an atheist
your secular leftist
you go around talking about human rights
all the time you've got a real issue
here because what do you think
like what is a woman well what is a what
is a human right
what do you think a human right even is
where do you think it comes from
what are you talking about
now the people who came up with the
concept the concept as we understand it
today
and if you want to you know you want to
trace back the the lineage of this
thought process that that led to the
formulation of modern human rights as we
understand it you know you can decide
how far back you want to go
but the people came up with a concept as
we understand it today formulated sort
of the modern understanding of Human
Rights these were Christians
and it's very much grounded in a
Christian worldview of natural law
um of human beings created by God
endowed by by certain rights because it
just which which we we have as uh you
know thanks to our inherent dignity and
all of this is rooted in the fact that
we are created by this Transcendent
being that there is something beyond the
physical
um
that we are not merely
subject to and products of darwinian
evolution there's something beyond that
that's human rights
as it's always been understood
but if you don't believe any of that and
if you think as Diane Lau does that all
that is a bunch of happy horse s
then how how do you how do you hang on
to the human rights what do you think
that's grounded in
a human right must either come from if
it means anything at all
it either comes from God
or it it comes from man it comes from
the government
so either this is a human right is
something that's ingrained that we just
that we possess
whether it's recognized by the
government or not it's just we still
possess it
by our very nature so it's either that
or it's simply
words that we write on a piece of paper
you know governments decide what your
rights are
you have the right to do this because
the government said
and if they say you don't then you don't
anymore
but nobody wants to understand human
rights that way
they certainly don't on the left
you know when the Supreme Court made the
decision about Roe v Wade
we were told that by the left including
many of them secular atheists
they they said well no this is it
doesn't matter what the Supreme Court
says women have the right to abortion
what do you mean right
who says who
what are you appealing to exactly when
you when you talk about this mystical
right that that exists you're not
appealing to God what are you appealing
to
if you can only appeal to man if you can
only appeal to the government then it's
up to them what the rights are and it
doesn't make any sense if the government
says you have a right to this it doesn't
make any sense to say no that's that's
not true what do you mean it's not true
according to you a right by definition
is simply whatever the government says
this is a real problem but I don't think
anyone on the left has even attempted
the very few people on the left have
even attempted to confront or deal with
or wrestle with
um and it just makes everything they say
about human rights totally meaningless
all right
in response to Elon musk's takeover of
Twitter the media seems to have two
talking points basically one is that
Elon will restore Free Speech which is
bad and dangerous
and the other is that Elon will actually
restrict Free Speech which is bad and
dangerous and they seem to rotate kind
of between these two talking points at
will sometimes within the same sentence
so here's Joy Reid last night taking the
latter track let's listen
to those people the apartheid child
tweeted the woke mind virus is either
defeated or Nothing Else Matters
that came a day after he used his
platforms not only mock the lgbtq
community but also to go after America's
most visible Public Health official
tweeting my pronouns are prosecute
Fouche
not funny dangerous though
and the latest example of musk playing
his role in the rights attempt to
redefine Free Speech which to them
simply put is whatever conservatives
want said and nothing more
they've gone to Great Lengths in those
efforts and when it comes to social
media platforms as the Atlantic's Adam
server writes to use them for their own
political purposes including propaganda
disinformation harassment and message
discipline conservatives had to invent a
new constitutional right a conservative
right to post
and the Atlantic's Adam server joins me
now Adam your piece was excellent I want
you to explain for those who have not
read it and they all should what the
conservative right to post means
it basically means that you would have a
right to free speech as long as you are
staying what conservatives want you to
say
laughs
they just have no it doesn't it it they
are not worried about saying things that
um even pretend to reflect reality
uh and obviously of course this is what
conservatives were saying about Twitter
and about big tech for years and years
and years and we were told by people
like Joy Reid that this is all fanciful
and it's ridiculous and uh so on and so
forth and these are private companies
and stop your whining stop you and then
and then the the script flips and within
seconds they um
they they're you know they start
contradicting what they've been saying
for the last several years but in
reality see the conservative complaint
that
um people on the right were being
specifically targeted on ideological
grounds and shut down and censored
that was real that was actually
happening and we know that it was
actually happening we now have the
documentation it was obvious to anyone
that it was happening because we could
all see it but now we have the behind
the scenes and the documentation and the
email chains and we've seen all that so
now it's it's only been further
confirmed that this was happening
what Joy Reid is talking about as usual
is made up BS this is not happening
like they're they're there aren't any
leftists that are being kicked off the
platform simply for expressing left-wing
ideas
it's not happening it's simply not
happening and not only that
There's No One Calling for that to
happen nobody even wants that to happen
so while big Tech has been censoring the
right for years they've also been doing
it at the behest of the left has been
very open about the fact that they want
that to happen like these ideas are
dangerous you shouldn't be allowed to
express them
it doesn't exist on the right
it simply doesn't there there's
seriously no one saying that um that the
left should be shut down or censored on
the internet because for expressing
their ideas no one's saying that in fact
it's exactly the opposite
I want them
on these platforms
expressing their ideas I want that I
actively want it
and I'm not the only one
we just want it on a Level Playing Field
we don't want the the deck to be we
don't want the game to be rigged against
us to begin with
but as long as it's not rigged then
we're on a Level Playing Field and
things are fair to begin with then yeah
we want you out on the playing field
with us we we want you there
do you know why because we believe we
can beat you that's why we want you
there
it's like you don't have to believe that
we have that we that it's our you know
that we have some sincere passion for
free speech I mean we do but I'm saying
you don't even have to believe that
because on top of uh believing in free
speech
there's also the I don't know if you'd
like to say more selfish motivation that
we want to beat you and embarrass you
and I'll make no secret about the fact
that that's my that's what primarily
motivates
me that's that's the primary reason why
I believe in free speech
but but even more than that why do I
want the left on Twitter posting so that
so that we can expose them
because they cannot win these arguments
they cannot win any of these arguments
if the if it's a Level Playing Field
and they will inevitably humiliate
themselves and that's what I want to see
happen so yes I want joy read on the
platform please keep posting
please do that
it's just that they're terrified now
they're terrified and they're running
away
because the game isn't rigged
because it is a Level Playing Field
and I know they can't win on those on
those grounds
all right
one other thing uh I wanted to get to
briefly so Candace Owens attracted
the attention of our PR reps at Media
Matters yesterday they published this
headline and shared the clip on Twitter
from a show yesterday uh the daily wires
Candace Owens uh quoting her I actually
think that society would be safer if we
discriminated more and they actually
published multiple clips of Candace
scandalously suggesting
that discrimination can be justified or
even good
uh and these were posted by Media
Matters yesterday
I thought we've already talked about
what is woman what are human rights and
so uh we'll continue on this theme of
definitions what is discrimination
because what Candace has said here is
obviously correct so this is yet again
Media Matters getting upset about
something and anyone listens to it any
normal person listens to it and says
well yeah that makes sense of course we
talking about
um it's obviously true here's what
discrimination means
to discriminate
okay until they until they change the
definition of this too in uh
Merriam-Webster but even if they do it
still means what it means uh to
discriminate means to recognize
distinctions that's what it means to
discriminate
that's all that's discrimination it is
to recognize distinctions
and so if you recognize a distinction
between one thing and another you are
discriminating
and that's why in the old days we you
know you might describe someone you
might say this he's a he's a very
discriminating person but it would be a
compliment because what you're saying is
that this person is uh that they're that
they have the powers of discernment
and they're able to in their and they're
very able to recognize distinctions
that's all discrimination is
if you if you can look at one thing and
then another thing and say those two
things are different you have
discriminated
and that means that we all discriminate
every single
second of the day I mean every every
moment of the day that you are engaged
in thought you are discriminating you
are recognizing distinctions I don't
think it's possible to be a sentient
being without that ability
because the only other option is to look
and think that all things are exactly
the same there's no that we're just
living in this uh you know hazy mess of
nothingness and there are There's no
distinction from one thing to the next
that's all discrimination is
um now
you could discriminate wrongly you could
discriminate unjustifiably
um you could discriminate unfairly all
those things are possible
but discrimination in and of itself is
not unfair just because you're doing it
and this is also true of people so like
there's the obvious things where if
you're if you're drawing a distinction
if you recognize that vanilla
chocolate's different than shot than uh
than vanilla ice cream is different than
chocolate ice cream you are
discriminating between the two types of
ice cream
and nobody would have uh I don't think
anyone would have any moral problem with
that although maybe some people would
find a way to
um that's the easy thing
but what about discrimination again
among people
if you're discriminating but you know
one person
distinguishing one person from another
is is that wrong well obviously not
I mean in any kind of context
you're drawing distinctions between
people
I know we say that
it's illegal to engage in discrimination
while hiring
well it's obviously not literally true
you wouldn't be able to hire anyone if
you couldn't discriminate
like you have you have a job posting you
have a certain position you want to fill
and you're looking for the person who
will best fill it and so you're
discriminating against the people who
will not be good in that job in favor of
the people who you think will be
it's discrimination
so
Media Matters yet again
another swinging a Miss what else is new
all right let's get to the comment
section
you know men don't like going to the
doctor it's time consuming expensive and
in some cases embarrassing Rex MD is a
trusted leader in men's Telehealth they
make it easy and inexpensive to get
generic and branded Viagra or Cialis
online no waiting rooms no embarrassing
trips to the doctor no insurance and no
co-pays with just a few clicks of a
button you can talk to a medical
professional create a professional a
personalized plan and get the products
discreetly shipped straight to your door
within two days did you know Viagra
could cost around 90 a pill Rex MD
offers a generic brand that's just as
effective for as low as two dollars a
pill Rex MD has already helped over 300
000 guys gain confidence quickly and
conveniently and they're here to help
you so take advantage of their best deal
yet at rexmd.com Walsh save up to 90 off
by paying only two dollars per dosage
starter packs of generic Viagra or
Cialis are now available to get started
that's rexmd.com Walsh for up to 90 off
go to rexmd.com for more details and
safety information
Amica says I think a lot of people who
participate in the preferred pronouns
thing actually confuse pronouns and
personality just because we all have
different personalities doesn't mean we
get to modify the language whenever we
see fit well you're exactly right that
is 100 what they're trying to describe
so really
they're trying to come up with pronouns
to describe personalities which just
doesn't
make any sense and that's not what
pronouns are meant to do
um max says watch Brittany Greiner get a
book deal and a Netflix documentary as
soon as she lands on the U.S oh
are you kidding me
she look she's gonna put Kaepernick
Colin Kaepernick to shame if you think
Kaepernick cashed in on his faux victim
status you you ain't seen nothing yet
just wait wait until uh Brittany Greiner
gets done this is going to be
I mean she's got my prediction is within
a year she's gonna be worth over 100
million dollars on endorsement deals and
and Netflix and book deals and
everything else cashing on the victim
status 100.
um
just Keating says you really did have a
big year Matt in a fairer world you
would have at least been a finalist or
even an honorable mention for times
person of the year
I could not agree more thank you
um Dan says I'm a big fan of Jordan
Peterson but I'd like to know what Matt
thinks about Peterson's war on Anonymous
Twitter accounts
yeah so this has been uh this has been
something that has gotten some people
upset of Jordan Peterson on on Twitter
and I don't think it's a new thing I'm
pretty sure that Peterson is always made
this argument against Anonymous accounts
and I don't want to speak for them I'm
not sure if he actually thinks that
Anonymous accounts should be banned from
social media that you should only be
able to have an account if you have your
actual name and face attached to it I'm
not sure if he believes that or not but
uh certainly he you know thinks that it
would be better if there were no
Anonymous accounts on the internet now
I don't agree with them I used to feel
that way you know there was a time when
I when I would have agreed with him and
I can understand
why you would feel that way
especially if you're in the public light
and you're
voicing your opinions all the time and
uh your face is out there and you've got
your face and your name attached to it
and then inevitably you know we all end
up getting doxed and even our addresses
are out like everything is out there
about us and we're putting our name in
our face with it and um and then
we or when you're doing that and you're
constantly getting criticized by these
Anonymous trolls it's hard not to
respond by saying oh you cowards you
don't even put your yeah it's real easy
for you to do hiding behind your
Anonymous status coming after someone
who's put you know it's like I've put
everything on the line here and you're
putting nothing on the line hiding
behind it while you fling insults
and it's true that the anonymous
accounts who do that
they're they're they're merely Anonymous
so that they control people who are not
Anonymous and that's all they're doing
yeah they're just nothing but couch
but the reason I changed my mind about
Anonymous accounts in general is that of
course that's not what even the majority
of anonymous accounts are actually doing
um
it's they're
not by and large
trolls who are trying to hide behind
that Anonymous status it's more that
you know they want to use these
platforms because these are people who
don't have jobs where it's your job to
express your ideas
um they have other kinds of jobs but
they want to use the platforms and they
still want to be able to participate in
the kind of conversation
um
but if they do that with their name and
phase attached to it then they're just
opening themselves up
to having their lives destroyed to being
targeted fired all these kinds of things
that won't happen to me I'm not going to
get fired just because I express my
opinion on social media that's my I get
paid to do that
but if you haven't uh you know
a job that is not in the media
and you do that with your name and face
attached to it
then you've opened yourself up to that
so if you get rid of the anonymous
accounts what you've really done is
you've just you've just
taken the away the ability of a lot of
these different people to to participate
in the conversation at all
which would be a very bad thing
you know
and this is this is the game the left
plays too by the way it's like they you
know if you say something they don't
like they want to know everything about
you they want to find out everything
they can about you not not because they
uh are really interested or because they
want to give you an award so they want
to find the stuff out about you so they
can destroy you
and we don't want to make that easier on
them
all right Dennis Robinson says
yes there was an uprising by my wife and
I to see our grandchildren during the
alleged pandemic yet it was my afraid
children of ours that kept the
grandchildren from us we are still
attempting to restore relationships
meanwhile Mallory says I was extremely
disappointed in my mom and my
mother-in-law both dads didn't seem to
worry so much but the grandkids were the
grandmothers were afraid to come around
any of their grandkids even through
Christmas 2021 thankfully they've
stopped the nonsense but I lost faith
and family a little bit I've heard
many stories like that so many stories
of uh
families where you know I think in many
cases the Rifts that were opened up the
wounds uh
damage may be permanent in some cases
when you've got family members
you know there's a sickness going around
and you have family members that will
tell you I'm okay
not seeing you indefinitely
just so I don't get sick
that's a statement that people are not
going to be able to forget
and then uh Raptor man says whoever was
in charge of the Wardrobe for this
episode really needs to be reprimanded a
tan suit for our Sweet Daddy is just
plain evil was it tan I feel betrayed in
that case because this is this is the
position I'm in as a colorblind uh
American I didn't even know that it was
tan but I've made my feelings about tan
suits very clear so I feel somehow
violated that I was put in a tent suit
without my consent or my knowledge but
thank you for letting me know about it
it's time to kick woke companies out of
your man's bathroom Jeremy's razors is a
premium Men's Grooming company that
shockingly doesn't hate men they've got
a full range of men's Staples including
a Precision 5 razor with a flip back
trimmer tea tree and argon oil shampoo
and conditioner body soap facial
moisturizer and lots more it's uh got
this his whole routine covered with hair
body beard and skin care products that
are made right here in the USA it's a
win-win you love that he's cleaning up
without uh parabens or sulfates he's
gonna love supporting a company that
doesn't hate his guts Jeremy's raises is
100 woke free and now you can get 30 off
this gift bundle when you order by
December 15th switch your man over to
Jeremy's razors to kick woke out of his
bathroom go to dailywire.com Walsh today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
well I regret to inform you my friends
that the nurses are at it again we all
remember the coveted days when nurses
across the country were posting
choreographed dance routines to tick
tock constantly complaining about being
overworked and understaffed even as they
turn the hospital's hallways into a
scene from High School Musical it was
annoying it was insufferable and it
exposed a troubling weakness in the
nursing community that is their need for
attention which is of course a weakness
shared by almost everyone in our culture
among nurses it was put on display yet
again uh with a slightly different style
of video this week NBC news reports for
labor and delivery nurses at an Atlanta
Hospital came under Fire over a tick
tock video in which they shared the
things that annoy them about expecting
mothers and their families the nurses at
Emory Hospital or Emory University
Hospital Midtown were participating in a
popular Trend where users share their
icks or turn-offs about a person The
Tick Tock Trend originally began as a
way to for someone to describe why they
stopped dating another person
I can already tell you one of my icks
which is people using the term ick to
describe their pet peeves I know this
might come as a shock to Tick-Tock users
but we actually don't need a cutesy new
slang term for everything
now I realize that every generation is
entitled to come up with its own slang
but this latest generation has grossly
abused that privilege
there should be laws governing this like
if I was Theocratic fascist dictator I
would allow
maybe three new slang terms to enter the
Lexicon every 25 years
each generation gets to pick three not
three in a week but three total
in any case bringing it back to the
nurses not to jump ahead and spoil the
ending but according to NBC it would
seem that they have been fired uh it
says quote Emory Healthcare said the
video was disrespectful and
unprofessional and does not represent
our commitment to Patient
family-centered Care we've investigated
the situation taken appropriate action
with the former employees responsible
for the video the company said an
Instagram post
so former employees possible never
specifically confirmed that they were
terminated for the video but I think we
can logically assume that they didn't
all happen to retire Suddenly at the
same time so it appears therefore that
this video was a bad idea here it is
my egg is when you come in for your
induction talk about can I take a shower
and eat what my ick is when you ask me
how much the baby weighs
and it's still and it's still in your
hands dad comes outside and asks for a
paternity test right outside the room
door saying you don't want any pain
medicine no epidural but you are at an
eight out of 10 pain just to serve a
deal and you're still closed fingertips
well we've already told you to push the
call light but every five minutes your
family member come back at the front
desk
excuse me can have a blanket another egg
when you're going room to room between
one baby mama and your other baby mama
oh Nick
see that it's the unlimited trips to the
nurse's station for me
well ladies the good news is that you
don't have to worry about any of those
icks anymore the bad news is that you're
going to discover a new ick which is
called unemployment
I can understand why you were so
frustrated I mean it must be difficult
when your patients are a bunch of
domineering prima donnas constantly
making outrageous and haughty demands
for exorbitant luxuries like
food and blankets
next thing I know you're going to tell
me that they even sometimes request
anesthesia before surgery
I mean these are these are divas we're
talking about now I admit
there might be something uh there might
be something to some of the the
complaints they Lodge in that video it
wasn't all unreasonable I would also be
annoyed and kind of grossed out by a man
who has two children being born by two
different women in the same birthing
unit though that sounds more like the
plot of a 90s comedy starring Eddie
Murphy than an actual real life event be
that as it may
some of the complaints seem valid and
I'm sure there are plenty of nurses out
there who could make many other
complaints even more valid and
defensible than the IX these ones
outlined in fact I know they could
because I have nurses in my family and
I've heard the stories
but there there are two points that
these ill-fated tick-tockers fail to
understand and these are lessons that
all of us no matter our careers would do
well to keep in mind
first you go into the same job every day
okay you have helped hundreds of
patients if that's your job so you have
been asked for blankets and food
hundreds of times and and every slightly
annoying or silly or thoughtless thing a
patient might say or do you've
encountered dozens and dozens of times
so you feel
the cumulative effect of all of those
little annoyances
but your patients don't
so this is a job to you this is
something that you punch in and punch
out of every day but if you work in the
labor and delivery unit for many of your
patients it's a Once in a Lifetime
experience on average these days it's
not any more than a twice in a lifetime
experience nobody is in there having a
new baby every three days unless it's my
wife we're talking about this is always
the tension between employee and
customer employee and clients employee
and patient
you're both involved in the same
experience but the experience is
fundamentally different for both of you
because of your roles
for you it's a job but not for them
so part of your job then
is to not bring your weariness and
annoyance into the experience
yes you've been asked for a million
blankets yet the patient asking you for
a blanket right now isn't cognizant
about that or thinking about it and
shouldn't have to
you should treat the patient like their
needs are the most important thing to
you and then treat the next patient
exactly the same because that's what
you're being paid to do and it's
difficult but that's what you're
supposed to do no matter what your job
is you're running a cash register at
McDonald's each pay each not patient
each customer who comes in you know the
the the number one value meal you you've
you've punched that in a thousand times
but this should be the you should act
like this is the most important thing in
the world to you getting this person
their Big Mac
yeah you're faking it but that's your
job is to fake it
second everybody complains okay there
there's no sense in complaining about
the fact that people complain people
complain about their jobs about their
families about their personal struggles
their health problems Etc everyone has
complained about all of these things
but what people seem to not understand
these days is that there is a proper
time and place for these complaints and
there are improper times and places
there are appropriate forums and
inappropriate forms there are people in
your life you can can and should
register these complaints with and
people you shouldn't
and making a complaint publicly on video
for the entire world to see is very
rarely the correct time place Forum or
audience
generally you should be complaining to
someone who a
can actively do something to solve
whatever problem you're having or B is a
trusted Confidant who can listen and
provide you with meaningful support
so if your complaint is something that
nobody can reasonably solve and it's not
serious enough to Warrant the
consultation with a trusted confidant
probably best if you just keep it to
yourself
because stifling a complaint telling it
to no one ever
is also an option and one that should be
selected far more often than it is
when it comes to complaints about your
job just a complaints about your family
a great majority of them will fall into
this last category
like they're complaints and you should
just never tell anyone if you could
believe it there should be there should
be a whole list of complaints that you
have
about people in your family about your
job that you never tell anyone
because there is no one in your life who
needs to hear all of that or should have
to
grenin Barrett
and and the rest should be articulated
to the appropriate party within your
family or your job they should almost
never be aired in public for the entire
world to hear because the public can't
do anything with your gripe we can't
solve your issue for you
we don't know you we aren't your friends
so we also can't act as your trusted
confidant
all we can do is listen to your wines
and think to ourselves wow I wish this
person would stop whining that's all we
can do with it
and then we get back to our own lives
and our own Petty annoyances
whatever you were hoping to get out of
the public airing of your grievances you
almost certainly will not get
unless in these nurses cases they were
hoping to get fired in which case
mission accomplished and not to add
insult to injury but I must also say
that along with being fired they are
today uh needless to say canceled and
I'll do it for this portion of the show
as we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
thank you